delta chron actually started when these
sequences were uploaded to an online
database of sequence data called gized
uploaded by a researcher in cyprus the
genome of so-called delta chron appeared
to be a new hybrid variant it contained
a spike protein that had some of the
same mutations as omicron in it but a
saskatchewan virologist says that
quickly turned out not to be true rather
what scientists believe is an error made
by a sequencing machine as it picked up
traces of another virus in the room had
it arisen by evolution
in cyprus
then you would expect all of the
sequences to be quite similar in the
other portions of the genome but they
weren't so not a hybrid says zoology
professor sarah otto but not an
impossible scenario it's called
recombination when two viruses co-infect
the same hosts and exchange genetic
information studies show this has
happened before with variance alpha and
epsilon but experts say hybrid does not
mean stronger more often than not this
results in a virus that's not as good at
being a virus
a false alarm that is still sounding out
as a science communicator i was getting
a lot of
messages my emails and dms from people
being really really worried the danger
wh officials say is in the misleading
name suggesting a super virus was born a
michigan linguistics researcher is not
surprised we're certainly in a time
where we've seen that misinformation can
really take off
so
people i think are being very careful
especially government organizations
about how
they
describe particular variants some have
called it the panoramic the morona virus
and even believe it or not the panini
new terminology like deltacron can catch
like wildfire and experts say be
detrimental to the fight against covet
19 when emotion takes hold
if you have even a small portion of the
population
fearful you will see changes in
individual behaviors in terms of
compliance with public health measures
and some say even distracting the public
from the real danger and that is
unchecked spread of omicron
ibrahim global news